تهانينا ،
شكرًا لك ، سأجعلكما تنظران
إلى الكاميرا هنا من أجلي ،
هذا رائع أمنح هذه الطريقة ، يرجى
إلقاء نظرة أخرى هنا بعد
أن لا تفكر الابتسامات في الليالي التي لا تنام
جيدًا ، مرحبًا ، مرحبًا ، تهانينا ، شكرًا على
قضاء الوقت  أعلم
أنكما يا رفاق يجب أن تكون مشغولًا حقًا
ولكن
هل يمكنك أن تخبرني أن هذا كان مثل
أن تصبح أماً جديدة وأخبرنا
قليلاً عن
Baby sussex كما
نطلق عليه أمرًا رائعًا إنه رائع
جدًا وأعني أن لدي الاثنين  أفضل اللاعبين في
العالم ، لذلك أنا سعيد حقًا
وأخبرنا قليلاً عن أم
ابنك ، ما الذي يعجبه هو أنه
ينام جيدًا يا عزيزي نعم لديه
أحلى مزاج إنه هادئ حقًا
وقد كان للتو  لقد كان الحلم
يومًا مميزين ، فهل يبدو أنه مثل
أي شخص ما زلنا نحاول معرفة أن
الجميع يقول إن الطفل قد تغير
كثيرًا على مدى أسبوعين مع
نوع من المراقبة بشكل أساسي لكيفية
تغيير المحترفين  يحدث الغش خلال هذا
الشهر المقبل حقًا ، لكن مظهره يتغير
كل يوم ،
لذا من يدري وكيف تجد الأبوة
بشكل عام
ما هي عليه لا تزال لحظة خاصة ،
نعم إنها رائعة والأبوة والأمومة مدهشة
،
إنها مجرد يومين ونصف اليوم
الثلاثة  أيام
ولكننا نشعر بسعادة غامرة لأن
لدينا مجموعة صغيرة من الفرح وأن نكون
قادرين على قضاء بعض
الأوقات الثمينة معه لأنه
يبدأ ببطء في
النمو وأنا أكره أنك لست خارجًا لتراه
شخصان مميزان في دقيقة واحدة
، الملكة والدوق ، نعم ، لذا
اصطدمنا بالجيب بينما كنا نسير بجوارها ،
وهو أمر لطيف للغاية ،
لذا ستكون لحظة رائعة
لتقديم الطفل إلى المزيد من أفراد الأسرة وأمي
معنا  بالإضافة إلى ذلك
، إنه
شعر رائع أيضًا
فقط في العائلة جميل ، شكرًا لك ، شكرًا
لك ، شكرًا
جزيلاً ، شكرًا لك وشكراً
للجميع على التمنيات
الطيبة واللطف
الذي يعنونه كثيرًا
لك